la gendarmerie qui est qui permet en
fait surtout de réguler le trafic qui
tourne autour de cette place de la
bastille qui est souvent très fréquenté
vous voyez derrière moi aussi on voit
ici
des agents de la préfecture de police de
paris qui vient qui font plutôt régulier
trafic met donc en tout cas en ce qui
concerne le l'encadrement et la sécurité
il n'y a vraiment aucun souci aucune
tension aucun problème puisque
clairement ce n'est absolument pas
l'objectif de cette population d'acteurs
de la culture que de susciter merci pour
ces précisions va aller à la rencontre
de ces acteurs qui sont réunis en ce
moment place de la bastille on a le
spectacle vivant par exemple qui
reprochaient vous regardez les chiffres
en préparant ce qui représente qui
représentait en tout cas un 2018 qui a
contribué à hauteur de 2 6 milliards et
demi d'euros à l'économie française
voilà pour les chiffres que vous pouvez
retrouver notamment sur le site du
ministère de la culture merci d'être
avec nous en tout cas j'attends vos
réactions vos commentaires sur
lefigaro.fr bonjour jean paul qui nous a
rejoints si vous avez un établissement
culturel aussi que vous souhaitez salué
un théâtre musée dans lequel vous vous
rendez fréquemment dans votre ville ou
dans vos déplacements si vous venez je
sais pas à paris à lyon à marseille par
exemple dans des villes plus petites
n'hésitez pas au théâtre national de
bretagne a le tnb à rennes par exemple
n'hésitez pas on est là aussi pour
prendre vos réactions vos commentaires
tout de suite on retrouve thibault qui
est avec et bien l'actrice du monde du
théâtre me semble-t-il
exactement merci madame darden parler
parce que vous pourriez m'expliquer quel
monde vous élever leur présenter
aujourd'hui mais je m'occupe d'un
théâtre de marionnettes dans un parc à
issy lui
le théâtre polichinelle et demain je
pensais reprendre mais comme on sait
en plein air mais abriter donc c'est un
établissement recevant du public et donc
je peux pas recevoir du public
vous avez été arrêtés depuis le premier
jour et non non
j'ai pu reprendre le 30 mai la jusqu'à
fin octobre
avec toutes les mesures barrières
les mesures sanitaires j'avais c'était
sur réservation dont j'avais pris les
téléphones des gens cas où il ya un
problème
des infections pour des séances parce qu
obligatoire les enfants devant les
parents derrière avec 2 un peu
distanciation et et même s'il y avait
des parents qui ont des ciseaux les eaux
france était possible et les gens
avaient bien intégré à un tous ses
gestes barrière dont je pensais que
c'était possible en plus moitié de jauge
à 30 au lieu de 50 maxi donc je pensais
vraiment que demain c'était c'était bon
alors qu'économiquement
quelles sont les conséquences alors moi
c'est que j'ai mon statut d'intermittent
donc il n'y a pas de souci la compagnie
est là le fonds de solidarité donc
peut il ya les payer les charges
un report de charges non six mois c'est
ce que je veux c'est qu'on rejoue quoi
c'est qu'on puisse rejouer voir cette
possibilité d'être confronté au public
c'est pas en allant de chef pas d'argent
avant de pouvoir et ouvrir et pouvoir
distraire
les enfants et leurs parents voilà on a
par exemple beaucoup de déclarations on
voit beaucoup de bien représenter
aujourd'hui qui estime qu'on est en
train de tuer l'actuel genre qu'est ce
que vous en pensez ça
c'est vrai que si si ça se prolonge il
ya beaucoup de compagnies et beaucoup de
théâtre qui vont fermer de même laissé
les cinémas c'est c'est catastrophique 1
les la fréquentation
les gens se tournent vers les
plateformes
les films alors que le cinéma c'est
aussi une sortie c
voilà c'est un moment convivial et on
est en train de perdre ses automatismes
donc c'est vrai qu'on le monde de la
culture s'en servir
c'est l'argent qui n'est toujours furent
une avenir très incertain france
l'exposition mois de janvier c'est le
manque de perspective en jeu le projet
que je les pessimistes en mai par le
rina
on parle d'une troisième vague
en janvier c'est moi j'aimerais
reprendre le plus vite possible mais
c'est assez
très incertain merci beaucoup tes
voyages cas vous avez beau faire
soutient dans notre chat en direct ces
témoignages et cette dame qui est donc
bien en lien avec les théâtres de
marionnettes les théâtres de
marionnettes dans lesquels devant
lesquels on est peut-être allé quand on
était enfant devant lesquels on emmène
peut-être nos nos enfants nos petits
frères et soeurs nos cousins cousines en
tout cas total soutien à leur combat
nous disait nous dit à l'instant franck
franck piccard bonjour bienvenue sur
lefigaro.fr total soutient leur combat
je salue les artistes de rue et les
autres aussi nous dit jean paul voilà si
vous avez et bien des commentaires
n'hésitez pas à nous les donner je vois
qu'on joue du violon juste en face de
vous thibault est ce qu'on pourrait
s'approcher entendre 1.7
alors dieu sait
rien n'est fait en effet dans du bronze
et bien
à vendre avant d'aller voir violon si ce
n'est quand même pas une décision en
voyant ces marches de l'opéra bastille
ici même et comme dans certains autres
endroits de la capitale
on a pu voir bien déjà le monde de la
culture manifesté ces dernières ces
derniers mois que ce soit pendant le
confinement avec on se souvient ses
spectacles de l'opéra bastille sur les
marches de l'opéra ou également sur
l'opéra garnier avec et bien les les
membres de l'opéra qui faisait les
spectacles mais on a eu aussi un petit
peu avant cela ils sont là vécu tous les
deux en direct pierre et bien
participation du monde de la culture à
des manifestations importantes ces
derniers mois et donc eh bien il faut
rappeler quand même que cette situation
particulièrement complexe à vivre pour
le vent de la culture elle intervient
dans une cour dans un contexte qui était
déjà en tension assez importante avec le
monde de la culture entre eux à l'époque
le ministre de la culture qui restèrent
et et bien c'est l'acteur mais
aujourd'hui manifester une nouvelle fois
on va justement aller voir cette chose
de violon pour lui pour arriver aux
oreilles prix à faire un petit tour on
va revenir s'ils se remettent à jouer la
partie
merci en tout cas pourquoi pour ces
précisions thibault on est toujours sûr
aux images qu'un beau temps sur la
capitale beau temps alors qu'on avait
récemment eu faim pomme était aussi en
direct alors qu'on avait dans la moitié
ouest et en particulier dans le nord
ouest du territoire ces derniers jours
pas mal d'intempéries pas mal de vent
pas mal de bourrasques effectivement on
avait suivi notamment sur figaro live je
vais mettre un petit peu de bien dans
mon micro puisque
mieux maintenant comme ça je disais que
on avait suivi ces derniers mois est
effectivement comme le disent et ivo les
mobilisations du monde de la culture
notamment contre la réforme des
retraites c'était en fin d'année 2010 9
début 2020 je me souviens titre
personnel aussi que et bien devant sur
les marches de cet opéra bastille avait
été jouée le 31 décembre dernier juste
avant le passage dans cette nouvelle
année elle avait été déjouée bien tout
simplement la marseillaise on va vous
faire vivre un peu l'ambiance devant
l'opéra bastille et on va retrouver
thibault qui va vous montrer ces images
qui va vous faire vivre cette ambiance
vous continuez de réagir de nous donner
vos commentaires de saluer aussi les
lieux culturels qui sont près de chez
vous quand vous aimez visiter n'hésitez
pas je prends vos messages dans le tchat
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je profite qu'on voit sur ces lieux qui
vous aurez l exception culturelle pour
revenir sur les propos tenus par jean
castex ce matin sur sur europe 1 je mets
un petit peu dit un de vos dents micro
pour vous puissiez bien m'entendre le
monde de la culture c'est l'exception
culturelle mais ça n'est pas l'exception
sanitaire disait ce matin le premier
ministre un jean castex nous avions
planifié en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie un retour progressif vers
l'ouverture de ces établissements il se
trouve et bien qu'en france comme
partout en europe les résultats ne sont
pas assez bons 7 janvier au mieux
il faut aussi contextualiser en
rappelant que hambourg faisant découvrir
c'est en vous faisant découvrir cette
information que à l'image des
restaurateurs ou des professionnels des
stations de sports d'hiver et bien des
acteurs du monde de la culture ont les
acteurs au sens large un pas seulement
des acteurs connus comme vous allez
retrouver ce soir devant le théâtre de
l'atelier à paris mais voilà des
syndicats notamment ont saisi le conseil
d'état pour et bien déjà médiatisé le
combat et puis pour essayer d'obtenir
surtout la la réouverture de ces
établissements culturels au plus vite
recourent déjà relayé par près de 500
structures dont alors les acronymes ne
vont peut-être pas vous parler mais la
fédération des théâtres indépendants
d'avignon avignon évidemment au lieu du
du théâtre lui et son festival qui a été
le in hell of qui ont été annulés cette
année et puis il ya les selles nous
obscures les salles de cinéma qui se
mobilisent également
si près de chez vous vous voyez une
salle de cinéma à lui mais ce soir entre
17 heures et 18 heures hé bien c'est
normal puisque et bien à l'appel de la
fédération nationale des cinémas
français bien on se mobilise
on se mobiliser pour montrer sa
mobilisation on allume les salles de
cinéma ce soir entre 17h et 18h sera
peut-être une nouvelle info espoir si si
vous passez devant le cinéma non
malheureusement ils seront pas ouverts
vous n'avez pas pouvoir aller voir une
séance mais c'est un acte de
mobilisation parce que oui la culture
c'est aussi le cinéma et tous ces films
qui n'ont pas pu sortir ou qui sont
sorti brièvement sur les écrans
ces dernières semaines avant toutes ces
mesures la fermeture des établissements
recevant du public le couvre-feu le ou
encore bien évidemment ce deuxième
confinement on va retourner sur le
terrain dans un instant je vous rappelle
qu'on est à bastille dans ce
rassemblement des acteurs culturels qui
manifestent pour contester le maintien
des fermetures alors qu'on avait parlé
du retour potentiel du public le 15
décembre mais face aux indicateurs
épidémique et bien ce sera le 7 janvier
au mieux
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
christian sur lefigaro.fr merci d'être
avec nous je salue également les celles
et ceux qui nous suivent sur notre
chaîne youtube on va retrouver thibault
tiens qui a pour nous une pancarte
thibault
[Rires]
ce sont les paroles des vendeurs que
j'ai entendu c'est moi
l'heure du ternois a bouleversé et
le souffle
personne dans
de l'installation de ski
ça va
vous êtes issu du monde de la culture
vont travailler dans d'autres milieux
procure
je suis enseignante
dans la fable la dimension de l acquis
l'expression
et quelle expression des actuels que
forme d'expression est absolument
essentiel
on nous en crise
[Musique]
de cette liste
il
et je m'arrête rollin parce que je suis
comment vous le concevez les grands à
venir j'imagine que c'est aussi en poids
psychologique pour vous en tant que
citoyen il en particulier pour toute
cette jeunesse qui
quels acquis et la force qui
une autre espoir
toujours pour le futur et que l'on
empêche de s'exprimer qu'on empêche nous
que je pense qu'il faut rentrer en phase
i
ans et à partir du moment
des temps plein sont sont ouverts que là
une certaine spiritualité pour cela il
faut aller ce tiercé espace pouvoir
risquent tous les espaces la sensibilité
les ingénieurs de chacun d'eux
je sais à qui
bon assez touchés
c'est essentiel de forme
lorsque vous êtes des manières
j'aurais dû
voilà vous le voyez pierre c'est
intéressant il ya évidemment un grand
nombre de personnes vivant de la culture
qui sont venus manifester aujourd'hui
mais également des citoyens qui
ne dépendent pas directement de ce
milieu mais qui est bien sentent aussi
cette pression qui représentait paraît
bien ce que l'on vit désormais depuis un
peu plus un peu avant le mois de mars
c'est à dire une période déjà difficile
sur le plan sanitaire sur le plan
économique mais également psychologique
pour le moral et le quotidien de
nombreux français merci pour ces
précisions cette nouvelle interview
thibault en direct de la place de la
bastille devant l'opéra bastille où le
monde de la culture se mobilisent
journal y aura une autre mobilisation
c'est ce soir 18h30 devant le théâtre de
l'atelier dans le xviiie arrondissement
du côté de montmartre un pour les
connaisseurs et les connaisseuses je
vois que jean paul est un connaisseur
lui par exemple paris sans les théâtres
ce n'est plus paris effectivement
effectivement c'est vrai qu'on on a de
grands théâtres un pari on parlait de
l'atelier il ya une parisienne
du côté de montparnasse aussi vous avez
du côté du 9e arrondissement un tout
près des locaux du figaro où il avait
énormément de lieux culturels et de et
de théâtre bonjour avec respect qui est
avec nous aussi les gens gardent leur
masque dans les cinés et les théâtres
alors pourquoi reste-t-il fermer une
raison et bien justement je vous propose
qu'on soumette cette question à
l'interlocuteur
même si sa liberté de mouvement me
paraît un petit peu compromise à l'heure
actuelle mais qui va en tout cas être
interviewé par thibault il aurait tout
de suite
bonjour monsieur vous semblez bien
fragile
est-ce que pourriez m'expliquer quel
monde vous êtes venir présenter
aujourd'hui il ya d'abord je pense que
la poésie c'est ce qui sauve le monde
la poésie est très forte houle barthel
mais elle est fragile à la fois pour la
poésie puisse traverser le temps
traversé l'esprit pour nous rendre plus
fortes
mais cette force passe par la fragilité
alors justement pourquoi avoir choisi le
message de la fragilité
en ce qui concerne ce monde culturel
aujourd'hui parce que si nous sommes
uniquement dans la solidité dans la
matière dans l'appropriation on ne peut
pas s'élever au sud ce monde s'élever au
dessus de ce temps qui avance trop vite
on ne peut s'élever que si on accepte la
part de fragilité et paradoxalement si
la culture aujourd'hui qui est en
fragilité elle même mais peut-être dans
un excès fragilité vous même vous
travaillez dans le monde de la culture
vous avez une profession différentes
alors moi je suis solidaire de ce
montage a fait partie de la grande
cohorte des spectateurs des amateurs
les utilisateurs de la q2 utilisateurs
de la culture se secourir
et passer un sentiment de tristesse en
fait et figurines qui anime ces le c'est
le coeur qui et c'est le coeur qui est
touché une des beautés de paris s'est
par exemple son nombre de yards varier
la ville du monde qui a le plus de
terrain des théâtres qui sont
microscopiques ou immense
ça fait partie le coeur battant de paris
est là
ça fait quand même un moment un certain
nombre de mois qu'on peut observer cette
espèce de pression sur le monde de la
culture sur le moral de beaucoup de
français pouvoir voulait conserver
personnellement les mois à venir en
terme justement de morale d'ouverture
psychologique et aussi de 2
de bonheur entre guillemets culturel je
pense qu'on a un moment heureux
aujourd'hui paradoxalement puisque là on
va approcher le 21 décembre c'est la
renaissance que la lumière est
symboliquement je pense que la situation
va s'améliorer je viens avec l'espérance
l'espérance de cette fête de la lumière
qui a été fêtée dans toute religion dans
toute civilisation au moins dans
l'hémisphère nord et on est à la preuve
cette renaissance est d'ailleurs vous
voyez tourner votre bête tourner votre
caméra wi bénéficié déjà les prémisses
de ce jeu ce serait en train de renaître
qui est revenu à aujourd'hui on dirait
pour le monde de la culture
un petit clin d'oeil merci merci et
bonne journée
voilà vous le voyez c'est intéressant
pierre ans et deuxième interview de
suite avec non pas des acteurs de la
culture mais des usagers clairement qui
est bien s'appuie beaucoup sur ce monde
de la culture au quotidien dans l'année
et qui est bien aujourd'hui sont venus
manifester aux côtés des différents
acteurs qui osent sont directement
touchés et économiquement et
personnellement dans leur quotidien par
les conséquences économiques de mercy
thibault pour pour cette interview alors
je fais une petite collection une semble
avoir dû le tf le théâtre des bouffes
parisiennes tout à l'heure c'est le
théâtre des bouffes-parisiens jeu
il me semble un peu comme i7 cette
petite erreur et la personne interrogée
tout de suite ses spectateurs interrogés
par partie bout il aurait disait que
paris s'était aussi cette ville où on
avait des toutes petites salles et
j'essaie de retrouver le nom je les
retrouvais c'est le théâtre de la petite
loge dans le 9e arrondissement de paris
ben on est vraiment au coeur de la
capitale théâtre de 25 places 16 mètres
carrés seulement et une mini scène de
deux mètres carrés qu'elle en fait le
deuxième plus petit théâtre au monde en
a il ya quelques années j'en avais
entendu parler alors est-ce qu'il a un
toujours ce classement en tout cas on
parle du deuxième plus petit théâtre au
monde derrière le sillage de rob small
convenience en angleterre voilà pour
pour l'information comme quoi on a on a
des grands noms on à mogador aussi
toujours dans le 9e arrondissement qui
on a des des salles tout petit et puis
bien sûr en région vous avez évidemment
tous ces autres établissements culturels
d'importance artistes art triste c'est
ce qu'on peut lire sur cette pancarte
sur ce morceau de carton
brandie par ce manifestant toujours
place de la bastille où se mobilise le
monde de la culture pour constater pour
constater oui constater qu'ils sont
toujours fermés puis contestée surtout
ce maintien des fermetures au moins
jusqu'au 7 janvier prochain
et ben on verra on verra si le monde de
la culture a la chance de pouvoir
rouvrir dès le début dès le 8 janvier
dès le début d'année on le souhaite
évidemment et on verra on verra où en
est la situation épidémique d'ici là je
vois du monde qui nous a rejoints dans
le chatt merci mathieu d'être avec nous
bonjour merci d'être avec nous mathieu
vous nous dites concernant les séances
de cinéma malheureusement pour avoir vu
ça de près les masques tombent
une fois la séance de ciné démarré alors
c'est vrai que pour vous parler de mon
expérience personnelle je suis allé voir
quelques films mais je me suis dépêché
puisque vu la vitesse à laquelle on est
reconfirmer sous couvre-feu sous
restriction et cetera je me suis dit on
va aller on va sans qu'il y ait quelques
films comme on dit pour profiter avant
qu'on soit à nouveau restreint et moi
c'est vrai que j'ai plutôt favorisé les
les séances du matin je sais pas si vous
arrivez à vous lever le samedi matin le
dimanche matin les premières séances du
matin déjà c'est moins cher déjà c'est
moins cher donc pour le portefeuille
c'est plus sympa et puis surtout vous
êtes peu nombreux donc bas dans une
situation épidémique comme celle qu'on
vit cette année bat c'est quand même
plus pratique et c'est vrai que moi
j'avais pu constater et c'est vrai que
je fais un peu office de police visuelle
quand je vais au cinéma mais j'avais
constaté quand même que les gens gardent
et bien leur masque même si c'est
tentant quand on est dans une séance à
une dizaine une vingtaine de personnes
dans une salle immense de 2 300 400
places de retirer le masque mais non les
gens jouer le jeu et les clients les
spectateurs joué le jeu et et gardez
bien leur masque après vous savez quel
ce questionnaire en ce moment pour
savoir où est-ce qu'on se contaminent le
plus
alors est-ce que les parages pas encore
regardé si on avait des informations
précises et là dessus je sais pas ce
qu'il en est des des salles de cinéma en
tout cas bon mathieu merci pour votre
votre retour on comprend que dans les
dernières séances ciné que vous avez
faite le
le port du masque n'était pas forcément
très bien respectée merci en tout cas
d'être avec nous on est ensemble pour un
petit quart d'heure encore ensuite on va
laisser place aux questions au
gouvernement en direct de l'assemblée
nationale on n'entend pas mal d'ambiance
autour de vous qui vous est ce que on
sait s'il y aura d'autres mobilisations
du monde de la culture dans les jours
dans les semaines qui viennent
[Applaudissements]
alors malheureusement
j'essaierai de m'approcher sur la
console et pour faire bénéficier un peu
de l'ambiance ici mais comme je suis à
la recherche d'une interview je peux pas
trop approcher parce qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de bruit en ce qui concerne les
nouveaux appels mais on en n'a pas
particulièrement pour les différentes
professions qui sont touchées à un temps
du côté des restaurateurs du monde de
l'événementiel du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie commis hier c'était le cas
sur l'esplanade des invalides
là on a pas d'appel non plus tout cas
pour les jours à venir en terme de
rassemblement du mois parisien et du
côté du monde de la culture bien c'est
pas rien il faut dire que du côté des
appels à manifestation bien c'est
souvent avec quelques jours d'avancé que
cela est annoncé mais on peut
difficilement prévoir d'une semaine à
l'autre pour ce genre de rassembleur me
merci pour ces précisions
on a éveillé les différentes
mobilisations que ce soit celle du monde
culturel ou d'autres milieux comme les
les restaurateurs hier on vous fera
vivre tout ça évidemment dans au pur et
à mesure des mobilisations même si
effectivement on est peut-être un peu
tous tournés vers les fêtes de fin
d'année une bouffée d'oxygène peut-être
un tous souhaitée par tous
mais effectivement un pour de nombreux
secteurs comme l'hôtellerie restauration
comme le le monde de la culture
c'est une fin d'année avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'amertume
on est toujours en direct de bastille où
on va entendre ce que va nous dire une
nouvelle un tir interlocutrice à la
caméra et au micro de thibaut ysore qui
vous est venu représenter aujourd'hui
dans cette manifestation
alors
vous des remous la caméra la caméra tél
on peut coller ensemble et à regarder
vous en faites pas je suis venu
représenter
moi-même élus tous les compagnons c'est
à dire
tous mes compagnons
corps de métier c'est à dire tous les
secrets dans le spectacle vivant ce soit
des musiciens des danseurs metteur en
scène
un dvd
[Musique]
pas du tout le monde comédiens chantent
un rêve là parce que
c'est scandaleux et
après je vais vous répéter à fait ce que
tout le monde dit mais ils se tapaient
possible de 4 par exemple de faire
vraiment bien sculpté les cours
je veux dire c'est vraiment ça bien
l'endroit où ça peut être contrôlables
ok après bon les festivals nous à maman
auxerre de guy pages comprend même si
c'est pas dans un conte ses racines
on va tourner et fermé d'un freddy est
génial
on n'arrive pas ma ma
[Musique]
n'importe quoi ça donne envie qu'on
fasse une sortie mais athée
dans les supermarchés du sweat à tout va
comme ça mais un
rager les spectacles mêmes s'attaquent
aux bleus même simple que ça m'agace
saga s'est passé
normal c'est le nom ici je me suis dit
tiens on peut faire un truc alors moi je
les ai vus cupr nakata tournée compagnon
d'irina m'attends à une barbie du tube
macabre mais ya ce côté mais cet habitat
de rang puisque aulas on est un peu
entre dean est protégé d'un sens où
marié en corner mais les retombées vont
être catastrophiques
il ya le manque aussi de vient de
pour créer ces et création il implique
beaucoup de sens
pour les 10 ans et c'est ça c'est cette
structure puisse inclure à tricoter des
histoires qui est des gens pleurent car
de manière incroyable a travaillé des
heures et des heures quand elle est
négative de 7 avant moi j'ai des
trapézistes il agit une amie c'est une
nana ce génial qui est très forte qui
tourne beaucoup qui a beaucoup tourné
car beaucoup de métier mais ma très
disciplinés très travaillé et là elle en
train de se décourager parce que c'est
il
et surtout arriver à atteindre le niveau
de professionnalisme gosnell on en a
besoin d'être
même en contractant mais on est booké
alors on se prépare et on joue il ya le
plaisir du public
il ya plein de facteurs j'en parlais en
effet deux mois sur les des jeunes alors
ça guérit pas comment on peut vraiment
s'accrocher c'est des heures les gens
comprennent que c'est des heures et des
heures de mobilisation de la
mobilisation créative et ludique d'être
ensemble aussi fait y'a plein de choses
et les gens des faits de le dis c'est
pas super 10 ans et pendant ses vacances
à mandanda des mises et on va encore
créer pendant six mois se passe pas
comme ça en fait
moi j'ai un diable est plein de gens qui
sombre dans le dollar c'est ce que
j'entends en tout cas depuis tout à
l'heure en baladant à travers la faune
c'est que déjà il ya les conséquences
économiques sur la dramatique pro milieu
culturel mais il ya aussi une volonté
commune de
même si c'est pas pour pour de l'argent
pour avoir des revenus et au moins
d'enrichir de continuer d'alimenter
lebreux culturelle française au
quotidien ça non mais c'est ça c'est ans
passés un peu j'ai un coup c
cette espagne des pas mal d'autres
métiers aussi mais même si j'ai
dénigrement par edmond plein de gens
même parfois l'a déjà proche c'est plus
du métier a commenté un bas justement
plein d'idées comme ça pour que les gens
se réunissent patrick participe à petit
plainte de familles de l'initative les
makes
on n'a pas de costard financier pour
échapper à
à la destruction d'une entreprise quoi
grassi dur
on continue
alors limites d'une ronde et raphaël ses
actions comment vous entrevoyez le futur
vis-à-vis des conséquences économiques
des mois à venir on sait même pas quand
est-ce que le monde culturel pourra
reprendre ses activités
comment personnellement on entrevoyait
si tu oses que c'était une option serait
de malheureusement devoir quitter le
monde de la culture de devoir peut-être
quitter le monde de la culture pour va
trouver une offre un travail alimentaire
ou quelque chose
est ce que vous pensez vous pouvez vous
aider de manière personnelle je suis pas
à moi seul
je suis têtu quand même gentil quand
même mais je crois c'est titre
individuel il ya pas mal d'années il ya
pas mal de déceptions des cas le projet
de mais moi j'ai pas eu trop projets
musicaux qui se remet à l'eau s'il était
né sans vous tous qui est naissant des
grosses structures seront du ressort à
et même encore elle voilà je suis même
pas ce qui va se passer
khaled est ce qu'on dit
je sais quand je ne sais pas et si tu ne
comprends pas si vraiment on est
considéré à la joie des copains qui
donne du sel qui joue dans les écoles et
dans les écoles et ses larmes aussi mais
ça fait déjà des années qu'on a beaucoup
de mon précieux être vraiment dans
l'éducation mais yagg et gagnez une
portée éducative à l'heure n'était pas
son disque à léguer quelque chose de
l'ordre de la dub éclairage à la mise en
éclairage d'ici de plein de choses
j'apporte à la réflexion ça réveille
d'esprit
évidemment et moi j'adore bosser avec
des mots
dès mai mais c'est pas que ça voilà
[Musique]
merci beaucoup de manifestations
voilà on est en direct sur le figaro le
figaro on en direct oui oui un pardon
c'était très bien c'était très
intéressant en tout cas ouais mais tu es
figaro manifestation culture
merci beaucoup voilà j'ai oublié de
mentionner qu on est en direct mais mais
bon vous le voyez que les gens n'ont pas
du tout de problème à s'adresser à nokia
est en tout cas pour conclure en tout
cas cette petite dose de terrain pour
cette fin de confinement bas ce que je
trouve intéressant de mentionner c'est
que on voit qu'un que delà des enjeux
économiques du monde culturel à
proprement parler eh bien ce sont les
enjeux directement de la culture
française au sens large qui sont ici
représentés avec vous l'avez vu
plusieurs personnes qui bien viennent
avant tout pour un maintien et une
persévérance dans ce monde de la culture
et surtout et bien continuation dans les
activités n'ont pas forcément pour à des
enjeux économiques même s'ils sont
essentiels on sait bien mais plutôt pour
mais revoilà pour perpétrer cette
culture française et tous et tous ses
savoir faire que l'on connaît aux
saintes c'est la merci beaucoup
thibault isaurine nous avoir emmenés
bien sur cette place de la bastille
devant l'opéra bastille poursuivre la
mobilisation du monde culturel bâti on
va finir en musique c'est parfait juste
un petit mot encore ce que j'étais en
train de faire des recherches en compte
et le chiffre m'a impressionné 23000
comédiens professionnels en france
moi j'aurais dit moitié moins mais en
tout cas on a 23 juillet c'est une
chance c'est une chance d'avoir autant
de 2
de bons acteurs et bonne actrice qui
sont à la fois connues et puis peut-être
moins connu en tout cas tout ce monde là
va aussi se retrouver ce soir au théâtre
de l'atelier devant le théâtre de
l'atelier à montmartre dans le 18e
arrondissement pour un autre
rassemblement en parler des figures plus
plus connu en tout cas celui là il est à
l'initiative des acteurs jacques weber
audrey bonnet françois morel nous ne
sommes pas des rebelles nous ne sommes
pas des révolutionnaires nous ne sommes
pas des agitateurs
nous ne sommes pas fous nous ne sommes
pas inconscient mais nous dénonçons un
profond mépris à l'égard du secteur
culturel et artistique temps nous
atteignons une apogée en matière d'
incohérences voilà pour le communiqué
bonjour et merci d'avoir été avec nos
kriss kross élan artères sur lefigaro.fr
un monde qui finira très mal bah non on
n'espère pas que ce monde de la culture
finissent mal leurs artères chris krause
qui nous dit michel rubio lavastre
démissionner à marseille alors ça c'est
de la politique et la politique
marseillaise une autre forme de
spectacle finalement et michel birault
l'avait effectivement faire un jeu des
chaises musicales avec son premier
adjoint benoît patience est à retrouver
sur lefigaro.fr c'est d'ailleurs une
info le figaro
merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir été
avec nous on se quitte en musique avec
thibault il aurait sur la place de la
bastille très bonne après midi
[Musique]
tiens
ah ah
[Musique]
elle parlera